what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch today don't worry
darling the movie starring Shia LaBeouf and
Chris Pine spit yes
I don't think we're talking about this movie
at all in this channel but it's out on HBO
Max so you know it was like people already
be asking us like you guys going to cover
it so yeah I figured why not let's do it Harry
Styles can do no wrong even if he's awful
in this movie we will not say that no no anyway
guys uh please go ahead leave a like John
how are you I'm ready to go to Harry's house
too I understand why Olivia did it and yep
I understand why anybody goes to Harry's house
also uh full-length Reaction watch Longs We
sync up with your own copy of uh don't worry
darling available for a super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page over there we cover many
things exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch along as they included thank you
to all for showing your support by following
us over there lastly this video is sponsored
by wondery one of our go-to podcasts it's
always exciting to work with a company when
you already use their services but we'll talk
on them more right after the reaction let's
get to the reaction
[Music]
does this take place in the past uh yeah I
guess it must [Music]
romantic Donuts
how many people I'm gonna be at this party
because I need to know how much tuna salad
Frank doesn't like tuna baby why didn't you
tell me I was planning on it being the centerpiece
to my dish oh it's not the centerpiece I still
feel like they're 17 years old playing older
you forgot your tuna Jack oh the tuna I prepared
the centerpiece
[Music] there's cheap stuff for her husband
I guess at home and privacy whatever floats
his boat maybe that's his kick
so they're all forced to take ballet classes
some kind of Stepford thing remember
late in control there is Grace in symmetry
is that the the theme of the movie the theme
of the movie
[Music] [Laughter] oh Jenna
[Music] smack her ass toots
[Music]
people said this movie's predictable I have
no clue what's going on same
[Laughter]
whoa what
he bought the magician's egg carton damn this
couple is so into each other how could you
not be there the two hottest people in the
world I made a roast house mashed potatoes
not eggs [Music] oh what a bunch of [__]
dude you just oh oh I've heard about this
scene
[Music] I've gotten much older you have ruined
the food
so I know you got a spoiled life here but
this all costs money it took time yeah if
you watch this on YouTube you you know though
yeah really see that okay you have to stop
humming that song what is it I don't know
I was hoping you could tell me it's been stuck
in my head for days maybe it's a children's
song some of your kids sing Oh no I don't
have children shame what is your purpose in
life well once you have one it's all the same
as how many babies should Violet have okay
something's not real yeah this whole life
is hollow and empty like those eggs and they
don't even care about the food
literally just ignore the food on the table
I haven't really gotten to talk to Frank very
much Frank doesn't have to talk to you oh
I'm sorry I didn't you have no idea how extraordinary
he is or what he can do you're lucky to even
know who he is let alone be standing in his
house oh my God Frank has built something
what he's created out here it's it's a different
way a better way and we only have each other
why are we here thank you
we shouldn't be here we're like one of the
only ethnic couples on your mouth shut you
know how hard it was good Margaret's question
is right it is the good question to ask why
the hell are we here I don't know man just
stand our ground to look harder to dig deeper
to mine that pure unbridled potential that
gem of Limitless and unimaginable value you
guys look like all you do is have fun I see
greatness in each one of you I know exactly
who you are
what are we doing changing the world what
are we doing changing the world that's right
freaking Nick crawls
oh they're hiding me suppression pills no
nothing is fine she just needs to sleep I
don't sleep I have bad dreams oh the 50s give
her a smack Sean Connery the before you lose
the decade man
and then it becomes unacceptable
gonna happen like every 10 minutes yep every
new location every new costume
[Laughter]
keep it going Chris likes to watch oh my God
what is going on
what is going on hey uh so she knew how dangerous
it was just like we all do the one thing they
ask of us is to stay here where it's safe
but still she dragged that little boy out
into the middle of God knows what you gotta
go there Florence Pugh so when they found
her she was alone they never found him I knew
he died I just hadn't realized she claims
they took him to punish her what is this like
is this area 51 development of progressive
materials but sometimes Peter insinuates that
they're actually making weapons and that it's
all happening underground because Frank discovered
it's scary to sacrifice something but you're
sacrificing something more by sitting in that
fear what you see here what you do hear what
you hear here let it stay here is it a political
commentary on suppressing women I mean there's
definitely a lot of that so far
oh my god oh what
oh my God
you need to drive out there it just crashed
I I can show you where it is drive it no uh
I don't go that way oh my God what's wrong
with you
oh you're gonna get in so much trouble
what if it's the little boy yeah he's just
been out here training to be a pilot this
whole time
Jared Leto's in there I'm just gonna stop
guessing
this movie gives me yeah I don't know what's
happening whatever I guess it'll be wrong
Jason Sudeikis is in there with so many divorce
papers
cool wow foreign
[Music]
I like that
supposed to be nice
are they experimenting on the women specifically
probably pills and all the they clearly must
control the food how long have you been home
a few hours okay now I guess don't worry darling
means ignore it yeah I got off the trolley
I saw a plane crash because I think it would
have heard if there was a plane crash no it
seems to be rather loud and I started walking
and um nope he's definitely making making
sure you don't um hey you okay don't worry
darling you had a really weird dream well
they're wiping memories around here man you
love me
the most oh he's been body snatched is it
some like Westworld [__]
we'll never find out now you're being conditioned
programmed [Music] is it our covenant until
tomorrow
oh crazy
ouch
this life is suffocating you
ow
e hello
you saw it she doesn't know what she saw
I can't talk to you right right now Margaret
no one asks any questions I would not do this
over the phone yeah they can listen
[Music]
don't question it
she's gonna invent hip-hop [Music] oh no oh
damn
[Music] foreign
okay so I guess none of this world is real
I like the music a lot Zach I got curiosity
and a panic yeah it's like really eerie and
disorienting no [Music] Margaret
[Music]
no no you're the only one with answers no
oh damn it Margaret save her Chip and Dale
oh [__]
stitches please don't get hysterical say the
title of the movie Jack
uh oh you know what I do Alice I'm a technical
engineer what does that mean what do you think
when I asked my mom what she does understanding
for years I don't know what you do
what does that mean what does that even mean
you know we can't come on what does it mean
what does it even mean not everyone gets this
opportunity and if you keep talking like this
you're gonna put it all at risk you're worried
about a demotion our life how is our life
together this we could lose this wow at least
he seems like he actually loves her in his
own weird way in his own very Randy kind of
way honestly I don't even remember
Frank gave us the opportunity of a lifetime
wow
thumbnail
them clicks oh [__] she didn't even realize
that all what she just did did she nope not
at all oh she wants to break free
but I was quite a tumble she was so embarrassed
talk to her it wasn't a tumble
she slid her throat Alice ah no no no witnessing
a trauma can often lead to distorted memories
even nightmares let's get some gaslighting
in here I have some pills I can prescribe
for that uh I I really don't think that I
need those they're precautionary security
risk they will just keep you relaxed they're
bad doctor let me have my security risk envelope
exposed this isn't a problem we can handle
it ourselves well I'll just keep that on file
what did you do to Margaret you still don't
understand how she's okay you wouldn't want
me discussing the details of your treatment
with my other patients now would you um [Music]
she was having significant troubles outbursts
paranoia she made impossible for Ted to do
his job so he no longer works for the victory
project uh oh a bit of help
not like you it's not necessary here it's
a totally different scenario what is it that
you Brit say cheerio Keep Calm and Carry On
[Laughter] [Music]
foreign
he left that there on purpose the yikes so
glad you came back you left this I forget
my head if it wasn't screwed on I wonder if
she remembers her life before this seems like
we've seen a flash or two maybe but she can
she consciously recall it I bet not
geez it's all redacted nothing [Music]
it's probably just all in code final warning
[Music]
might ask Shelly to dance at some point if
it feels like a good time you look incredible
or like she was just drowning that's how I
like my lady
that's a really impressive shot oh nice that's
good if they're like some type of alternate
reality and her her real self is she let her
sick and see through into it and are trying
to communicate to I wouldn't put it past it
maybe maybe we're in this maybe we better
explain it
I you enjoy [Music] [Applause] so Dina Von
tees she's a burlesque performer now so she
can't be playing herself I guess but [Music]
you are the ultimate product of this place
keep it together keep it together keep them
together Keep Together Jack Chambers whoa
I could have you up here for a bit
oh so did uh they watch like mid Samar and
say yeah get Florence Pew to do something
kind of similar here but like you know in
Palm Springs sterile desert 50s land let's
do that this man is out of the ordinary this
man I am in awe Jack Chambers I am honored
to invite you to join our senior Advisory
Board wow but he's just a boy and we got Big
Ideas he's gonna spit on you Chris
what's wrong what's wrong [Music] uh Alice
she's going down the road that's why I asked
earlier what her name was is I was like is
it directly in Alice in Wonderland yeah she
didn't slip it wasn't an accident I saw it
happen I saw her fall they're lying about
everything [Applause] [Music] and so I went
out there and I saw it you went out where
careful if you can't trust anyone man and
when I touched it I saw something and I keep
remembering more no I would not trust her
but you are behaving like a child your husband
is out there having the most important night
of his life he's being celebrated and you're
in here trying to rule exactly like and the
cycle hums
I'm ready for an awkward dinner oh yeah let's
get it going ask all the questions Alice I
learned something very exciting oh really
what's that rumor is you and Jack are trying
well we'll see we'll see a little boy
it's a man's world I'm sorry bunny didn't
believe you
[Music]
but then again you didn't believe Margaret
so
why should anyone believe you oh that's cold
no great man has changed the course of history
without being pushed to the limits of his
potential [Music] and you push me I do hope
you keep going uh-huh oh God uh oh look at
her walk it or walk Oh no just get this conversation
going people thank you oh
man Violet where are you from Philadelphia
I'm from Philadelphia are you serious I didn't
know that you know I liked most the women
here from Philadelphia yep or Baltimore or
Chicago ever noticed you got another thing
I for one do not miss the winter yeah she's
figuring it out what was the last Beach you
went to beaches are actually some of the filthiest
places in the whole world just a Sandbox of
disease do not say disease they need to know
I could probably guess Hilton Head Cape Cod
or the Jersey Shore they're all given a background
yes
right oh wow you were breaking the mold cool
that's how they met yes that's true I'm jealous
honestly it's such a smart story yeah yeah
laughs he's using all of us do you even know
what the veggie project actually is have you
ever asked do you is that why you went out
there no oh yes I did go out there and I went
to headquarters and I saw what he's hiding
he's lying to us he's lying to all of us about
what the victory project actually is he's
trapped us here trapped I hope no one feels
trapped do you feel trapped
no one's answering directly yeah tonight you've
trusted us in your home just like I trusted
you in my bedroom
what's in this world let's talk about that
where did it come from oh I'm sorry everyone
let's just think about it I'm sorry you should
clarify what he was implying about the better
of first yes your husband's not to think of
something else yeah that's a pattern isn't
there a pattern of selfish pampered whining
or is it just a desperation to be exciting
so manipulative well I won't listen to your
pathetic ranting any longer Well Jack I think
you may have over served your wife
oh yeah now it's your fault bro Jack let's
talk
played your hand go to the desert take the
car we need to leave and we can go anywhere
we can go anywhere and we can create our own
world and it will be you and me and we'll
be okay and it's not about where we go it's
just that we're together please please
I was acting off her I'd just be like wow
she's doing such a good job she's really carrying
me through this scene right now I'm so lucky
oh no
this is not an okay this is an okay to a different
decision
you're just gonna go down on her again hey
that's what they're working on a victory it's
just a giant pleasure wand I wonder if this
is actually the modern day oh is it is it
gonna be uh spoilers for The Village I feel
like they are in some type of Westworld type
of thing programming that they keep experimental
programming baby what's wrong all right so
I had to keep this from happening what baby
we need to go we need I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
the [__] [Music]
squeeze out of tear
oh yeah here we go it's MK Ultra time oh my
God look at the nurse
oh no no
I could withstand this
sorry
oh yeah maybe it is modern this looks very
like that looks modern day yeah [Music] oh
are they giving her a lobotomy oh
oh
I had a feeling from the beginning that it
was modern day okay
well it'd be nice to know that so he's not
British you know I there was a moment at the
beginning of the movie where he was talking
with a brief American accent and I was like
what what's up with this I was like what's
his voice yeah what's this accent and then
call the guy he couldn't come today but I'm
really tired baby that's me no Jax just stop
I just finished a 30 hour shift I sewed up
12 people and I gotta be back in six hours
and I'm so tired I just need to go to bed
30 hour shift you think you're running a YouTube
channel with that kind of hours and almost
as important work almost that that is the
real you I know that you are the man you say
you are Bond the ideal man all the game yeah
that fantasy stuff [Music] [Applause]
that's why he puts on the British accent so
they're trying to create a new Society yeah
I'd like it how do we join
oh my God
it is the most beautiful sign I've seen in
my life did you hire professional artists
to paint we made it ourselves I would love
it if Olivia Wilde knows the truth and she
chooses to just stick with the what this The
Narrative is I bet she I wouldn't be surprised
hi it smells amazing thank you I'm here for
my food and sex now well you're a little early
but I have so many things to finish so I'm
gonna need to go put things out of the oven
no it's gonna burn yeah there are things about
Chris Pine's character that feel like a cult
leader meets Jordan Peterson yeah yeah that
was a good call do you understand the discretion
required to be a part of this community yes
do you understand the consequences and discretion
are you aware that you are responsible for
preparing your home device system this is
Regency Shia LaBeouf yeah yeah do you consent
to the physical and mental requirements for
entry to Victory metaphysical where you are
responsible for the physical upkeep of your
chosen life ew
are you aware that you must exit the simulation
for victory headquarters every day and return
home for draw a live number of hours yes [Music]
miss you so they are in a simulation yeah
yeah this is the real modern right now yeah
because it's the red
okay yeah okay yeah
I guess we were right [Laughter] welcome to
the victory project yeah it's all a big simulation
two active users wow your re-entry has begun
into what we know is true to hold you they
don't need food
maybe you're having another episode just take
a deep breath it's okay
[Music]
think about your life and what you actually
want huh don't tell her that dude it's not
gonna go well for you she wants Freedom make
her own choices she wants to live in the real
world things that modern day women's though
I have to leave every day just to make enough
money to keep us here and I [__] every
minute of it I [__] hey Alice you get
to stay here and you're happy let's hear good
intentions right uh right it's the way to
view it definitely and definitely definitely
we would all do this
to you and you made me feel like I was in
crazy [Music] I'm sorry now's not the time
to go down that fixes everything the cheat
code a man's responsible for his own wife
and nothing else so all the wives are trapped
here yeah you didn't pick up on that reverse
step after Olivia Wilde yeah no I need it
[Music] thank you thank you everybody
what the [__] is he doing
got the glass yep oh
Alice
if you die in this simulation do you die in
the real world excellent question the Mind
cannot live without the body what happened
I was listening to me no I need to tell you
something funny to leave no this world isn't
real they're gonna kill you Frank created
a program and he created a world and it's
yep yep exactly Alice a man dies here he dies
in the real world Jack can't put you back
in this time he can't put you back in like
oh my God this is becoming an action thriller
let's go let's go stop some bullets
buddy your kids aren't real they are kids
aren't real they are the real thing is they're
real to me Alice because here they're alive
yeah yeah Christ Alice who whose blood is
that Jack go back inside Alice sweetheart
stop where is Jack oh Mur them all yeah
ah
[Music] that's right they all know deep down
they know
go go let's go hurry up yeah well you still
can
foreign
I love how these virtual reality programs
have to get into the car yeah [Laughter]
it's a little predictable guys I'm still really
enjoying it yeah I like this a lot for the
most part yeah oh
she's the she's become the bond character
yeah
[Music] what is about to happen
like chicken nice
that was clever well done good sir listen
to me you do not let her exit
oh
yep he's stupid
[Music]
oh my God what you have done is started a
revolution Liberate the women [Music]
like fire ants yeah God running Barefoot on
that yeah dude I know she has like fake feet
a little hobbit feet
hurry up
don't buy it
oh is she gonna choose to stay here she better
not no oh what okay
what
[Music] uh oh no go go go go go go go go go
go [Music] oh thank God once we acknowledge
that reality reality reality we can let go
go
[Music]
it's gonna be over now right color's coming
back [Music] beam me up Scotty [Music]
[Music] I disagree there's a lot to be worried
exclusively things to worry about
[Music] okay well it's over now
[__] to talk about yeah that was enjoyable
yeah I enjoyed it I don't uh I don't understand
the Guff this gut I I unders what I heard
I heard that there was um a divisive ending
so when I thought she was going to stay behind
was I was like oh that is [__] yeah because
I was like I heard it was a device defending
or something I don't remember what Rotten
Tomatoes said if they said something all right
yeah so now I'm like is it just divisive because
of the do you mean like yeah the the reveal
is divisive or is it the actual I mean I I
I watched it play out and I was like I don't
understand what the problem is yeah I'm not
upset really by any other by any of the uh
you know place it chooses I mean no I I think
the movie perhaps they're up on Rotten Tomatoes
but before that a word from wondering
thanks to wondery for working with us again
and sponsoring this video and yet again for
introducing us to another fantastic podcast
one that I didn't expect to be saying is a
fantastic podcast because it's a show that
I was like kind of up and down about over
some episodes that we really didn't like and
there were some episodes that we really liked
and a couple that we actually quite loved
it was such an up and down Journey but this
podcast from the first episode alone made
me go wow I already appreciate this show that
much more and that is the official the Lord
of the Rings the rings of power podcast first
thing they took me about this podcast is that
it's host by Felicia Day many of you guys
might know she's like one of the most Ultimate
Fantasy nerds out there I personally didn't
know about her until she was introduced in
Supernatural where I thought she was great
in it on this podcast ago Episode by episode
through the whole season and they interview
Talon from in front of the camera to behind
the scenes for example the first episode is
with I don't know you're probably a very small
risk Clark I believe the actress who plays
Israel she always pronounces the correct two
on the podcast yes while listening to it I
was like wow you know what I I like this first
episode that much more ready and I like Galadriel
that much already because I started to understand
a lot more of the insight and the approach
due to the fact that Felicia Day from both
just being a fantasy nerd but also being an
actress as well just gets the best questions
in there yeah I really loved it you're talking
to me about the finale recently yeah they
also had JD Payne and Patrick McKay who are
the show Runners on to break down the finale
and they talk about other episodes as well
across the series it's fascinating to know
because there's been so much made out of what
they have access to and what they have to
work with you know hearing what their reasoning
was for why they guided the season the way
they did and just the human elements of being
there day to day and you know making this
insurmountably big production is fascinating
stuff really I would say that if you enjoyed
the rings of power you're more than likely
going to love this podcast so please give
it a shot even if you were kind of just like
sort of we were in the middle if you were
like us to me it made the viewing experience
of the Rings of power that much more rewarding
so you know as they say here to go into the
canals of Newman
watch the rings of power on Prime video and
listen to all eight episodes of the official
the Lord of the Rings the rings of power podcast
for free on Amazon music you could download
the Amazon music app now I did that so join
me on that Journey Don't forget to check out
the Wonder app or subscribe to wonderyplus
in apple podcasts for more they're becoming
like the go-to center for my podcast so thank
you wondery for working with a loyal customer
all right here we are the ending isn't for
everyone but the cast especially Florence
Pugh helps don't worry darling make the most
of his story with fairly few surprises yeah
Chasm between the uh the critics and the audience
and I and I would I would be with the audience
on this one I would be with the audience on
this one because it's an enjoyable it's I
enjoyed it I like the I like the tone I like
the world the first like 30 minutes especially
reeled me in enough to the point where I'm
like I don't know what's going on but I want
to know yeah you know I wanna I wanna understand
what's happening and you know things did start
once you start piecing together pieces of
this that feel derivative of other things
you've seen yeah then it starts progressively
becoming like okay I'm figuring this out before
the movie's telling me what's happening I'm
figuring this out you know yeah yeah yeah
so it does become it's not like instantly
like I figured this out from day one from
the second it started there was like some
Clues I don't know what it was some type of
subconscious clue that felt like it was modern
day that's why I questioned it yeah the top
of like oh this is in the past um yeah I get
what you mean because I think I think they
do wisely in the early moments to sort of
there are places that do feel a bit Timeless
and I was thinking of Palm Springs because
Palm Springs is a place that's kind of like
that at least in my recollection of it so
yeah I feel like that's that's intentional
and then they do a good job of steeping you
further into the idea that this must be the
past but but yeah there's something and I
think that's a nice Nuance of tone that is
kind of tricky to strike to get you wondering
are we in the time in place that it's suggested
we're in because something yeah doesn't seem
quite like we are yeah man like a good Sci-Fi
story you know Matrix is like arguably my
favorite movie of all time I'm really bummed
about the cancellation of Westworld but there's
a lot of other than the Android part there's
things that involve a lot of with uh my manipulation
of the subconscious reality Distortion and
whatnot and uh you know realities that are
not real in one's own mind and so it's like
there's a lot of qualities in the way the
tone and the editing and the style of it it
wasn't you were pointing out Under the Skin
yeah and it was under the skin you said Black
Swan and one Alice in Wonderland reference
like there's a lot of things that most The
Village The Village Justice For The Village
yeah there's a lot that feels very um yeah
derivative of these qualities but I don't
know maybe if I saw it in the you know what
it is if this got like a 95 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes and then I watched it then I would
have been like I don't know guys I don't know
if I'm there with the critics yeah yeah but
she's telling me 34 and I watched this I'm
like it's not that bad come on it's pretty
easy it's an enjoyable film it's enjoyable
I thought it was really enjoyable especially
because the the acting from especially Florence
Pugh and Chris Pine who's that's a character
who doesn't have that much screen time when
you think about it but it's the kind of villainous
character whose presence needs to be felt
throughout like you'll hear them on the radio
a lot everyone's ideologies and their way
their entire way of living is all formed around
this cult leader yeah and who they want to
satisfy and get validity from is from this
dude so yeah I think that was well done and
like Florence pughes like phenomenal as always
like oh there are Parts just such a midsummer
type of thing to me yeah if you guys have
seen it half expected to see her covered in
flowers at the very end yes just watching
Harry burn up in a bear's costume yeah and
then you know some of the societal and modern
day political commentary I that's why I'm
more surprised the audience is [Music] so
very modern day political guys who feel emasculated
who just want to transcend their station with
their chosen partner and how do they do that
they go back to the good old days yes where
all you had to do was stay home honey live
your life and I'll go do soul-crushing work
in order to maintain the illusion yeah I mean
there's there's lots of gaslighting and there's
lots of just the idea the idolizing of yeah
the especially sort of 40s 50s past as being
something idyllic and and when you like deconstructed
is a lot of terrible things oh yeah yeah we've
done more modern day you know like [__]
like Mad Men that really shows yeah exactly
absolutely and so yeah it's you know it's
again not Illuminating this for the first
time like you said it's it's doing a lot of
things other media has you know tread the
ground of but I thought yeah this did it with
at least a very assured tone a lot of really
good filmmaking a lot of you know quality
performance like like all the work on display
is pretty quality so like in a weird comparison
to draw but I almost uh in this moment I'm
reminded of um what's the Tom Cruise Morgan
Freeman Joseph Kaczynski Oblivion uh Oblivion
okay yeah uh Oblivion is like clearly this
is derived of many other Sci-Fi movies however
I still like this whole kind of thing and
I would say that I felt the same way about
this but maybe more so like I maybe like this
more than that and uh yeah like there's a
fair amount of commentary you can draw on
you know especially societal and gender politics
and yeah like especially the way you have
Harry Styles as this guy who's clearly a bit
of a deadbeat and who clearly wants a better
life for them both they're both struggling
they must have some kind of genuine relationship
but he's you know it's no coincidence that
the fantasy he ultimately gets pulled into
this gift he thinks he's giving her yeah removes
all of her or at least much of her autonomy
it removes her you know vocation and it puts
all that stuff on him you know and yeah it
swaps it all out for a very traditional gender
role and that's I mean it may be a bit straightforward
the way it's like you know you basically do
all the work in supporting us and I wish things
were different um but yeah yeah I mean like
for for the mystery what you think of Harry
Styles you know uh I thought he was fine I
thought he I I kind of agree with the things
I had heard beforehand it's like I didn't
think he was bad I thought there were a lot
of scenes in which he was good I thought he
was uh you know you really believe him when
he and and Florence pure canoodling I feel
like the most and you know when he's in these
people enjoy those scenes yes yes they do
and uh and and you know when he is uh in a
more power position uh you know when he's
like breaking down in the car when they're
taking her away that was a moment where I
was a bit like okay like you know maybe get
a few more years of acting under your belt
and then you would be able to really nail
a scene like this so I I see some of the limitations
but I wasn't sitting here going like oh man
why they cast Harry Styles aside from his
status as a celebrity um and and it's one
of those things I like he showed up in Dunkirk
and I was like I'm not distracted by this
because I can see how and why you would bring
a person like him even with his status in
the modern world into a place like that and
what it says about you know who had to fight
that war and also he fits within that era
so then going to another story that's you
know within uh you know a past 1900s decades
aesthetic you know 30s 40s 50s-esque you know
Deco uh mid-century modern things like that
like he fits this time period well uh so you
know it's easy to kind of yeah like there
are things about his boyish charm and his
shiny appeal that lend themselves very well
to this movie so I wasn't sitting there going
like weird choice if you couldn't get Shia
LaBeouf because then you think of Shia LaBeouf
and you're like I could definitely see him
in the modern day sequences I'm very curious
to see how he would fit into the fantasy of
it all I think he would have been I don't
know if they would have made him British in
the fantasy I think that would have been very
distracting I find that more distracting than
Harry Styles doing in American and remembering
that Florence Pew is British doing Americans
yeah oh my God she's British that's right
oh my God it always blows my mind I totally
forgot that because I I hear her voice and
I'm like that like um uh is the kind of on
a personal note those are the kind of voices
I tend to be most attracted to Sir sure a
little bit of a raspy yeah she's got a little
bit of that Smoky yeah
um yeah not so much like the high-pitched
voices so uh you know that's all a woman sound
[Laughter] yep
they all sound like that it's really annoying
actually Selena Gomez has the kind of voice
that I'm talking about it yeah she got that
wrath too uh but um what uh wait I I think
I think sometimes it is hard to to look past
some of the
I feel like on my personal end it was easy
for me to look past it for most of the time
and just watch the movie and not think about
those other things other than a few jokes
here and there uh I I think Harry Styles's
performance made more sense to me once the
twist was once the reveal took place I would
like the more subdued because I think what
you might imagine what what I think the idea
of casting him would be is that for most of
the movie when you're in the fantasy world
you'd expect a guy who's really going to fully
embody the fantasy and really be sort of the
the presentation of it all really embody the
presentation of it all the quintessential
successful man in this Paradigm the the very
Charming very charismatic big personality
to then have a contrast when you see the modern
day and you're like he's not that at all he's
actually those like a pathetic self-loathing
guy that's greasy dude yeah yeah so I think
they want to have that contrast whereas I
think what Harry Styles was doing was keeping
that guy in the modern world alive in the
fantasy world and that's why I had more of
a sub like every other guy was sort of buying
into the fantasy yeah where he kept it a little
bit more like he was aware of the fantasy
and kept it subdued so I guess it's really
down to him that that's the I'm not I don't
feel like I agree with the benefit of the
dad I feel like that's what he was doing with
his performance and I I guess it really comes
down to is that choice did that choice work
for the movie or was it kind of like I'm not
really sure it's like I felt like there should
have been more of a of a gravitational pull
a more of a magnetism to his performance as
I guess what I was getting at you're supposed
to fall in love with him too yeah and I was
always like he's fine yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like he's fine he looks good with her
and I get how this relationship works I'm
not in doubt that they would be together however
Chris Pine brings you're never like fully
not suspicious of him but there are moments
where he brings that like I see what people
like get suckered in by this guy like you
mentioned that Jordan Peterson quality that
he has and uh yeah it really is leader meets
Jordan Peterson asked Meats yeah because I
listened to a lot of motivational people and
I've heard some Jordan Peterson talks that
are good and then I've heard some that are
really that are that are questions
I'm gonna say all of it's bad but there are
things that I've heard where I'm like I'm
[__] anymore yeah and I feel like that's
a good it is a good standard well it's not
a one to one he's clearly this guy like it's
a good uh stand-in because I think that's
part of the Frank characters uh deal as well
is there's probably a lot that sounds very
reasonable and very appealing and then there
are those nuggets where you're like whoa whoa
whoa hold on wait we're going to Extreme Measures
for some of this stuff yeah um but but yeah
like there's with the Harry Styles character
yeah the magnetism I think is a good word
it's it's that's the the Gap that needs to
be filled but I appreciated the performance
what I'm saying though is that I did appreciate
what he did in its totality once I got what
he was really doing when after the reveal
was shown yeah because within the fantasy
world the part that felt the most real in
terms of a big acting performance was his
ending moments with her um women they're like
fighting it out of the room where I'm like
okay like it was all sort of like this whole
performance started making sense like the
choice started really making sense to me yeah
the truth yeah next yeah yeah so um yeah not
that it was like a perplexing but hey yeah
I don't want to like spent too much stuff
[__] like that's like the Harry Styles
performance and it works I think it works
too because of the way the movie captures
the perspective like it it does keep you so
in Florence in Alice's shoes and so from her
perspective that even when you are in intimate
moments with them there's you're still disconnected
from everybody else yeah so I feel like yeah
that that lends itself to his performance
and the other ones as well well yeah because
there are times where it reads like is he
green is he withholding Charisma like when
he's dancing and stuff it was it was like
such a weird way of going about it yeah but
then suddenly when you know the reality you're
like oh it's all so the whole performance
suddenly clicked for me on the choice he was
making yeah yeah you know yeah and uh but
no I mean to me it's like this is Florence
Pugh's movie uh from beginning to end like
she's she's so phenomenal and she's great
it's a character who's like thrown into a
crazy scenario who's walking around the whole
time going what the hell's really going on
yeah it was almost a reminder at times in
ways yeah yeah which is like another one yeah
just start naming off this kind of movie I'm
the only normal one
yeah um and and uh and then you know I I think
what Chris Pine does is really clever because
sometimes very overt in what he's doing especially
with the writing uh but other times there
is that that type of uh sneaky Insidious quality
you know even when he's like drawn to Florence
Pugh it it it's like a it's something that
feels provocative and not not a a teeny bit
not a teeny bit supportive of someone's potential
yeah it's something to play more games with
oh sure yeah yeah it's the cat and mouse and
that's why that's why he's like I'm disappointed
yeah when she plays her hand he's like no
I mean I wanted you to like you know keep
unraveling this at a slow pace and yeah prolong
the game and make it some kind of Twisted
instead of yeah directly you know trying to
wreck this thing I've built for all my Bros
ears yeah I guess the movie's like not as
like clever as maybe he wants to be in it's
not that revelatory necessarily but it's really
I think it's a really enjoyable movie and
it was fun to play along like I had fun playing
playing along with the movie you know yeah
it captures its mystery well enough that I
yeah I I and I think you were there always
hooked always like what is going on always
a little on edge always suspect of things
like and yeah that makes it a fun engaging
experience and so I yeah I would put this
in a category with other films where you're
like yeah this didn't reinvent the wheel but
it rolled it with style you know it rolled
it with a plum yeah kind of like the movie
Oblivion yeah some people really hate that
movie and then I see it I'm like well yeah
I see what all your Inspirations are that's
fine I still like what you did it still looks
good I would still you know I'm not champing
at the bit to watch it again like ASAP but
I would happily watch it again yeah see what
other Clues might arise I really thought a
movie like this would get way more hate commentary
of pushing agendas and stuff because that
this is like so 2022. sure yeah you've got
a sad lonely dudes who just want to lock their
best girl into an old timey fantasy and run
their lives a woman being oppressed and wanting
their freedom after being chained down by
men and and also and other women helping to
bolster the system you know that these toxic
men have set up yeah you know that whole thing
like and for all the crap Olivia Wilde has
gotten for this movie like I liked her supporting
performance and that bit at the end is pretty
heartbreaking where like the way she played
that moment where where Alice like confronts
her about like do any of the other wives know
like clearly she is complicit in this horror
and you feel for her because yeah the whole
thing about the kids like and and uh you know
her loss and that but also the immense amount
of suffering and just the the events of wronging
of all these other people at the expense of
trying to maintain this fantasy for yourself
like I guess I would I want to understand
some of the other
go back and watch some watch this to see what
some of the intentional choices are with some
of the mirrors that linger or when what's
the girl's name who cut her on throat Marlene
Margaret yeah you're probably right Chip and
Dale Rescue Rangers uh oh that's her yeah
I was like I must be missing something that's
the only place I've seen her yeah she's the
the cop they work with um yeah is Margaret
yeah it makes sense okay uh like when she
sees Margaret in the mirror like I don't quite
get this but all right sure I think a uh a
mirror like like in terms of the rules of
what's going on that's not talking about the
rule like thematically it makes sense but
rules wise now I'm like wait a minute are
you doing something thematically that contract
that goes against your rules now now that
I understand this is a virtual reality program
looking at you it's just a glitch you don't
realize yeah for sure for sure or is this
just a pure pure hallucination of some kind
that just because Margaret is in your subconscious
that's what's showing up yeah yeah yeah that
probably makes you probably just did it right
there yeah the rules the rules I made up the
rules but yeah no stuff like that stuff like
that is fun to dissect and yeah I mean you
know you have that other bit where she's in
the many mirrors of her bathtub and then she's
got her one face that doesn't move you know
like I I guess yeah mirrors or the windows
to the subconscious in this movie and then
I I love that bit with I mean like that is
a I think like a pretty overt uh you know
magical style Choice when the wall presses
her up against the glass just showing how
constrictive this fantasy life has got to
break through he's got to break through the
glass ceiling the glass wall um I want to
be smart and try sure I can go and I can I'm
sure I can uh find my way into it via conversation
of understanding because obviously the things
about like you know creating the perfect woman
with the ballet but I also didn't fully I
there are parts of me that I'm like I don't
quite get the ballet part that they kept cutting
back to with the black and white and The Haunting
imagery yeah of it like why specifically this
ballet imagery is the is something I I can't
really articulate it feels like it makes sense
but I can't tell you why it makes sense there's
not like yeah there's not like one specific
explainer that comes to mind I feel like it's
sort of an amalgamation of like okay it's
very they're talking about symmetry it's very
symmetrical and in that way it's very hypnotic
yeah so you know that goes in line with the
sort of brainwashed element but also I mean
the life that they are doing here is a sort
of organized dance especially for the women
it seems like because you know you've got
dudes going outside who have to work and hate
their lives for 12 hours a day but yeah the
women are a part of this weird yeah synchronized
choreography that they don't seem to have
any control over that's running on this Loop
and uh and so yeah okay yeah and I like stuff
like that where it's like they're cutting
to it periodically and you're like yeah what
what is this what does this even mean and
then finally at the end you're like okay they're
projecting this this is part this is this
is actually diegetic in some way it's it's
in the film as they go into their hypnosis
you know alternate reality State see I feel
like I picked up on that early in the movie
and then it kind of lost sight of me it's
I think it kept doing like cut as it kept
cutting back to the haunting The Haunting
visual part of it like when they were actually
just doing ballet it makes sense but a haunted
visual stuff I was like I don't quite get
the the horror I kept going like to jump like
a ballet background what's going on well that
was actually it's funny I think we had we
had the yin and yang because I was like okay
I think I get with a point of this you know
like old-timey footage they keep chopping
in but you know like they actually have to
go to a dance class yeah you know like it
seems like they could be doing other things
but yeah I think that's just making that's
following that Motif probably because they're
all staring at it that's part of their lives
now in here is because it's so in their subconscious
yeah we all go to dance class and we get to
have our Black Swan reference too and I think
you know I'm sure Olivia Wilder to more of
this than people say I mean I I this is my
first I think Olivia Wilde joint but you know
you haven't seen book smart no oh that is
a hilarious movie I'm excited I want to see
it it is very similar in tone and style and
cinematography okay yeah I bet and then symbolism
two girls who are having a hard time saying
goodbye to each other ways the oppressive
Paradigm of academic learning of academic
Pursuits that's a funny ass movie that movie
um yeah no and I think it's impressive that
she can do a movie like book smart and then
put something like this together which is
just such a different film in every regard
like there's not you wouldn't think for one
second it's the same director and I think
it is really impressive that she was able
to do that and I like everything on a technical
scale from our design production design beautiful
the music is very haunting I love the music
um yeah it's a great score It's a Wonderful
score and I think yeah the direction I thought
was was good and I don't know I feel like
there is something that I can't quite put
my finger on that feels like it's a bit missing
for me in terms of the ramp up pace of it
all I guess I kind of wanted it might just
be a want but I felt like I I do feel like
it could have gone a little bit more anxiety
ridden sure you know I think it could have
it could have gone like mother it could have
gone like Black Swan where it's just like
this is [__] or Superior yeah this is
just like a mad house now yeah yeah lean into
that they did the whole thing with the blood
drop and the eye dilation and I'm like lean
into that like weird Beyond the Black rainbow
like surreal symbolism like yeah like really
go horrific I feel like if they had really
breached the outer sphere into horror because
it's you know it's a pretty solidly a thriller
of sorts and and two I don't know if if you
would agree but I feel like you could have
maybe done a little bit more in the grunginess
of the present to make things feel a little
more substantial there rather than just like
oh here's the reveal yeah yeah um yeah and
I think that's part of what there seems to
be a lack of a of an extra punch to it that
it's missing for me yeah yeah it's like I
feel like I would want to I don't know what
and I don't know if this is quite it but I
feel like yeah in those present-day moments
if it had said maybe one extra thing in that
environment in that context it might have
felt like you said that thing earlier about
this feeling like one of those movies that
thinks it's a little more clever than it actually
is and I feel like that is kind of a part
of that mixture I'm like okay cool here's
a reveal but you know and maybe might be cool
to get another revealer or another sort of
layer or Nuance on top of that especially
because it so much of this begs the question
of like what are all these other people not
that we need to see everybody in the real
life but even maybe like seeing Frank at one
point in the real world or something like
that um yeah I would have I guess it it feels
like it would have been cool like if she was
I think that the missing beat for me personally
I'm not a big fan of being the guy who's like
here's how I would make your movie I'm not
I'm not a big fan of that well actually here's
how I would make I'm gonna go for it do it
um where I was sort of missing for me was
really the because obviously it's going down
so like from the very beginning and from the
tiny bits I remember from the trailer uh that
I think I saw like once in the theaters is
that yeah she's gonna go crazy when everyone
else is she's gonna be uncovering the truth
everyone's gonna think she's crazy when she's
not right and I think like her descent into
going crazy could have hit home harder and
then it could have really had a like a gut
punch when Harry Styles does not ultimately
decide to leave with her so then it could
have it could have probably helped sell that
when she's back in the world like oh this
is how the movie's gonna end it's gonna end
with her she's been brainwashed again and
she's back in this world yeah and she's just
plopped there like it's a tragic end and you
can't escape yeah yeah like it could have
sold me on that but I was like I think the
movies just was also aware that no that's
not how it's gonna end so let's hurry let's
hurry through this mislead and it just like
kind of sped through the time when she's back
and it just went by so quick yeah then it
was like let's get to the part where she remembers
it again I feel like they could have you could
have yeah either convinced us more heavily
of that of the fact that yeah maybe she is
just gonna go back in and repeat the cycle
and I think you maybe could have we we all
know that by the end of the movie like we
all know she's right that she's actually and
I think that you could have maybe teased us
with like even though I think we would always
know if you'd at least given us some reason
to go like maybe she is a little crazy or
at least maybe what she's seeing isn't exactly
what the truth is even though something is
off whereas you're pretty much always certain
that she is absolutely right about what she's
been appearing yeah something that really
does feel like an anxious claustrophobic mess
as opposed to just doing visuals that represent
a claustrophobic mess something that really
feels like that and it didn't quite give me
that feeling but I was always watching and
focused on like what's going on I want to
know I'm enjoying it and I'm having fun trying
to figure out what's going on yeah but in
terms of the the feeling I never quite felt
what Florence Pugh was going for in spite
of the fact I'm aware she's phenomenal and
exceptionally believable I never found myself
truly In Her Shoes I never found a true self
as a true self-doubt in in the performance
like I felt I felt her increased paranoia
and fear of the series but yeah but pretty
much once things start to feel fishy she is
assured I didn't really ever get a sense of
of self-doubt or you know just the debate
within that comes before you decide no something
definitely messed up is happening here it
seems like she pretty much catches on really
fast which I don't want to necessarily begrudge
the character for being resourceful and observant
but at the same time for what this movie is
trying to achieve and for you know again like
you said it's engrossing the whole time and
that helps everything out but there's not
much in the way of like misleading you it's
more just like what truths keep not being
revealed yeah you know instead of oh I've
I've been uh you know swindled by something
yeah I I do think a performance like this
as much as I kind of respect the choice that
she never really quite goes am I crazy as
much as I respect the choice because it's
a predictable choice to do that at the same
time I'm I feel like that would make it more
human and would have helped elevate it and
it kind of feels like it's sort of like a
thing like this sometimes feels like it necessitates
the character really questioning am I am I
losing my mind am I crazy is this is this
me but instead it's it is a very much a I'm
committed to knowing stop me there's something
else happening yeah well I think they could
make the journey a little stronger if you
again I don't I don't want to take the the
strength of the character away because I I
kind of get the the argument for that as well
because there's so much made out of the gas
lighting that goes on in this movie so many
people are just trying to finesse her back
into the status quo and yeah I I I don't think
it would be reductive to have at least an
instance where some of that gas lighting does
get to her in a very focal way and then you
have to transcend and shatter that you know
that barrier like that would feel like a greater
sense of growth if you had that initial doubt
and then no no no I I was definitely right
and now I'm not gonna give up and now I'm
gonna freaking confront Frank at the dinner
table in front of everybody and be Brazen
and not care you know yeah I would have probably
would have made that moment hit a little harder
if she hadn't committed to like you know there
is something wrong with me it's not them yeah
maybe I will take my medication yeah yeah
yeah no and and then Frank confronts and then
it's like oh no [__] yeah yeah she's just
gotten back onto no no no I you know what
I was wrong everything's fine and then he
reveals that to her and then it's like oh
no wait what have I done yeah and then and
I think I gotta double down what what would
have helped too is I think if it if there
was like oh now we're in full rewrite territory
it is that's what we're doing let us man this
place another draft is what we're doing um
yeah
we're not changing the movie entirely we're
just like no we're we're just adding a little
bit more in there of what I think could have
helped it like when he is promoted because
what comes before the Frank unveils you know
like he's clueing her he's letting her know
like no you're right you know um you're on
to something but in private when he does that
scene in the kitchen between what would have
helped between that is if there was a confrontation
I think between Harry Styles and Florence
Pugh of you know her being like I'm telling
you you know she's going off and he's saying
like this is my big night this is my promotion
and you're making this about you like like
they get into like a really heated argument
and that's when she can come back to reality
of like I am Savage like she can take on the
blame of like I am sabotaging I'm sorry I
don't mean to I don't mean to do this you're
right this is your big night I need to support
you like if if a Creator real problem between
them the fact that he was promoted and she
wasn't around for it and she was in her own
[__] world and he's like doing a big old
song yeah and she's not there being supportive
at all it creates a real like riff in their
relationship and that's what helps Propel
her so it's like all right everything's gonna
be back no all in five let no let's let's
see if Frank can come over for dinner like
it's her idea and then and then that happens
at the dinner yeah and I'm like oh damn that
would have just made the attention of it Rising
it would have made the relationship between
her and Harry Styles feel that I think that's
what have given that anxiety thrust sure yeah
and because thinking about that moment I mean
in in the moment I wasn't like ah damn you
know they really missed out on an opportunity
blah blah no I never I was thinking any of
this yeah yeah but during but thinking back
on that sequence it is like I thought a bigger
conflict or acknowledgment of like you know
uh the thing in the bedroom yeah yeah him
like directly bringing that up those are two
moments yeah like Olivia Wilde in the bathrooms
like it's it's Jack's big day you're in here
you know like you're thinking about yourself
and being a child and there's never really
I don't really recall much of a acknowledgment
of that situation with Jack much at all and
then yeah you have that whole thing where
he point points out seeing them in the bedroom
and because it sounds like she she slept with
him sure it sounds like yeah and you would
think that amid all these different lies and
Illusions she would want to be like no that's
not what happened you know don't try and Gaslight
me further in front of everybody and make
me you discredit me in front of everybody
further I think with this discussion what
I do think is truly missing from this movie
is capturing the relationship between Florence
Pugh and Harry Styles feeling like the heart
and soul of this movie so that way it feels
very tragic by the end yes and because because
the tragedy doesn't hit you're waiting for
their relationship to dissolve yeah yeah like
the you don't really buy into it you feel
like there's something just suspicious about
him the whole time something's always wrong
and it's rarely ever like nah this is right
these two belong together yeah you're like
oh maybe he's a good guy you know it it doesn't
feel the tragic parts of it that want you
to feel like the tragedy don't hit that's
why at the very end I was about to be pissed
off with the movie because it doesn't feel
heartbreaking to me when she's thinking about
the you know her time with him yes of the
choice that I'm Gonna Let It Go like it doesn't
feel heartbreaking to me at all I'll just
be like no you're being stupid and go you
like it yeah especially with how the reveal
is portrayed where it's just like this this
deadbeat guy kidnaps his girlfriend puts her
in a simulation so that he can have his ideal
life with her well it's like they mainly just
it's like there's no it's just like sexual
with that man and yeah
it doesn't ever really feel like a real relationship
to me other than you got actors who are just
really going at it and and they're bonding
you know which in a weird way in a conceptual
way I don't necessarily begrudge the movie
for given what we see of the reality like
clearly you know they make a point in that
seen in the kitchen where he's like come on
I don't want to play around she's like I've
been working for 30 hours you know like and
so it makes sense to me that their relationship
would be so sexual and and that would be so
much of what we wanted but the other action
is not anything it's just so like but yeah
Baseline it's like they had to have gotten
together for a reason in the real world and
I still don't know what that is because you
only see the what could be construed as positive
in the simulation and thus you don't really
I didn't really get a sense for the Bedrock
of their connection yeah of their relationship
to each other yeah yeah it felt it felt like
they were it felt like they were paired together
it felt like a lot of these couples were paired
together by somebody else in a way yeah I
know that's why I kept thinking the flashbacks
were like yeah and maybe that was intentional
to make you feel like oh that's a different
yeah it's not a real husband yeah it was intentional
because it's not the real him um but still
anyway no it's a fun movie yeah had fun though
I enjoyed it yeah I enjoyed it I was like
yeah too much crap I had a feeling I wouldn't
be as bad as everyone said yes and yeah I
liked it I liked it no I didn't overall I
would say I liked it and I liked it I liked
it quite a bit I'm excited member of this
movie yeah this will be one of the one of
the films of 2022 I think back on like yeah
I remember this and uh I would love to see
Olivia Wilde Branch out into more strange
surreal genre stuff like marriage story like
marriage story yeah I want to see your take
on Revolutionary Road [Laughter] how many
more references can we pack in here what other
divorce movies whatever yeah yeah yeah there
you go there you go uh we miss any of there
any more there's there's some of that in 10
lasso the movie yes let's see the really positive
version of this now in in the movie that's
where Frank is the protagonist he is Ted last
time it sounds like it was a nightmare to
put together and uh
like I thought this isn't this doesn't feel
like a crazy hodgepodge mess like it definitely
doesn't it just feels like yeah I feel like
I could have used another draft um but it
doesn't feel like oh yeah the [__] there's
a problem
how embarrassing no not at all surprises are
not all right no there's tons of interesting
stuff and there's tons it feels like if there
were problems this would be the same movie
exactly yes no no no really because it is
it is a very assured and very steady-handed
movie you know it doesn't come across choppy
or anything like that no no or or tonally
imbalanced rushed at times but I think that's
out of your ordinary movie that happens you
know it's your it's her what second feature
film I think so so you know I've been impressive
yeah all things considered yeah definitely
you know this could have this could have fallen
so much more flat and it's really courteous
of a director to let your lead actor director
yeah that's right man I don't know what's
true I will take it that Olivia wild directed
99 of them all right yeah any any day Harry
wasn't on at least all right guys well what
do you think about don't worry darling leave
your thoughts down below go ahead subscribe
leave a like and uh thank you to wondery last
but not least let's do a patreon
Tyler Hague Tyler my friend T Hague with God
of War coming out ooh Ragnarok I am replaying
God of War which I first played on the PS4
he gave me forever ago oh uh this month I
am wanting to give a special thank you a proper
thank you that's why I want to say special
it's a typical Patron the day shout out thank
you they're all not not a run-of-the-mill
special thank you yeah there I wanted a a
first highlighting I want to take time to
First highlight the people who have been here
for a very long time you have been a consistent
supporter at our patreon page for 54 months
wow we do the math John 12 times 4 is 48.
12 times 4 is 48. it's like a year and a half
yes that's right oh no every time we fall
into this trap yes yes 12 times 4 is 48 and
there's 12 months in a year so we it'd be
uh four and a half years four and a half years
yeah I said a year and a half yeah yeah man
I was thinking four and a half of my head
don't don't confuse me like that don't take
me back to thinking it's weeks no no it's
four and a half yeah um four and a half years
man that's a long ass time thank you for being
here for so long and for never swaying from
us it's insane to have people like you at
our page and seriously you should make it
you should make a trip to California Los Angeles
dude I know you were out here once but you
were way far away and we couldn't make it
so come to directly right you gotta go like
10 minutes away from us yes that will make
time come to a beautiful downtown don't pass
like 15 minutes traffic to rain and then it
could be like a half hour and you know just
be a little too busy yes no man you gotta
you gotta you gotta come back out here and
and um we're better at making time for special
occasions like this so please make another
trip out here what the [__] are we gonna
do in Wisconsin yeah man there's not there's
only so many of this tree by your home look
at this tree we'll buy some Packers souvenirs
no no yeah we'll go visit Red Letters wasted
time you know that but that's all in an afternoon
what else are we gonna do thank you for being
you Tyler you're amazing I love you love you
so much bye you plated nachos when I see him
oh laughs